foreign
it's been nearly three years since
Meghan Markle and Prince Harry
dramatically announced that they were
stepping down from their roles in the
royal family and moving to America they
said that they valued their privacy and
could no longer tolerate living under
the white hot glare of the spotlight
their stated reasoning may have been
you know convincing to you at the time
if you were dumb enough to believe that
Meghan Markle was the sort of girl who
marries into royalty because she values
her privacy but if you're at least
intelligent enough to score higher than
an earthworm on an IQ test then you knew
that Harry and Megan were seeking
attention not shirking from it
and if you're in this latter category
the smarter than an earthworm
demographic you you have not then been
surprised to find that this private and
humble ex-royal couple has spent the
last couple of years
seeking attention wherever they can find
it they've done multiple tell-all
interviews one conducted by Oprah
they've signed book deals they've signed
multi-million dollar podcast deals Megan
has posed for literally every magazine
cover in existence outside of maybe Car
and Driver magazine although maybe she
got around to that too they have sought
a very peculiar form of privacy indeed
a form that involves appearing on every
sort of medium willfully attracting
attention and then monetizing that
attention this is the kind of private
life they wish to lead and now they're
going to continue their privacy Tour by
starring in a Netflix docu-series which
premieres this weekend and here's the
trailer
it's really hard to look back on it now
and go what on Earth happened
[Music]
all around the world she's becoming a
royal rock star
and then
everything changed there's a hierarchy
of the family you know there's leaking
but there's also planting of stories
there was a war against Megan to suit
other people's agendas it's about hatred
it's about race it's a dirty game
and suffering of women marrying into
this institution this feeling frenzy
I realized they're never going to
protect you
I was terrified I didn't want a history
to repeat itself
no one knows the full truth
we know the full truth
how many times are they going to milk
this exact same no one has heard this
before no one knows the full truth we
we've we've heard you tell the supposed
full truth about 46 times in the last
year
so I believe the official title of this
is uh give me attention the movie either
that or they're just calling it Harry
and Megan which is the same idea either
way of course everything that Meghan
Markle is involved in starting with her
marriage is at its core a publicity
stunt and a sham and this is film is no
different in fact eagle-eyed viewers
have noticed that between the two main
trailers released for the series
at least three of the images in these
trailers of media harassing and hounding
the couple are taken out of context
from events where neither Harry nor
Megan were even present
bbc.com has this report a photograph of
Paparazzi appears in for in the first
trailer just before a clip of Harry
saying he had to do everything that he
could to protect his family
however it is said to have actually been
taken at a Harry Potter Premiere five
years before the Duke and Duchess even
met a clip in the second trailer which
apparently illustrates Paparazzi
hounding the couple was actually taken
when former model Katie Price arrived at
Crawley magistrates Court last December
shortly before that shot the Duke of
Sussex is heard speaking of the pain and
suffering of women marrying into the
royal family adding that he did not want
history to repeat itself as a clip shows
men apparently chasing someone with
cameras the clip was in fact recorded as
price arrived to be sentenced over a
drunk driving chart one section of the
second trailer also features clips of
reporters photographers and cameramen
apparently in close pursuit of the
couple however one media Crush seen by
viewers was not targeting the royal
family right the royal couple but rather
president Donald Trump's former loyal
lawyer Michael Cohen leaving his New
York apartment in 2019 to serve time in
prison for financial crimes campaign
Finance violations and lying to Congress
profiling surveillance data harvesting
there are a lot of things I don't like
about tech Giants but there's only so
much I can do I don't have 44 billion
dollars to go buying up Twitter I wish
the good news is that you don't have to
be a billionaire to take a stand for
less than seven dollars a month in fact
you can join me and fight back against
big Tech by using expressvpn big tech
companies make their money by tracking
your online activity your searches your
video history everything you click on
they sell that dated advertisers who
Target you expressvpn helps you and
anonymize much of your online presence
by hiding your IP address so they can't
match any activity back to you I use
expressvpn on all of my devices to make
it much more difficult for big tech
companies to exploit my data for their
own profits it's incredibly easy to use
I just tap one button on my phone or
computer and I'm free to roam the
internet free from Big text prying eyes
if you don't like big Tech tracking you
and selling your personal data for
profit fight back by using expressvpn
visit expressvpn.com Matt walshow right
now get extra three uh three extra
months for free of expressvp PM that's
expressvpn.com Matt walshow
expressvpn.com Matt Walsh show so it's
pretty hilarious that they crammed three
misleading images just into the trailer
who knows how many lies they'll be able
to pack into the full series
it's also grotesque but that's par for
the course with Harry and Megan
these two may have ostensibly stepped
down from the Royal occupation but only
to exchange one throne and one crown for
another
because they are now king and queen
victim
and it is a symbolic figurehead type
position just like the one they left
but it also carries a considerable
amount of power in our culture not to
mention profit potential
they are in many ways
the perfect representation of victimhood
in modern Western culture
this is the service they're providing us
is by is by showing us what victimhood
really entails these days they are our
victimhood mascots
immensely privileged
certainly wealthy living lives of
unimaginable Comfort surrounded by
ostentatious luxury
they're celebrated by the media they're
fond over they're applauded
yet they can't stop whining they are
never happy none of their riches no
amount of public adulation will convince
these spoiled self-centered brats that
they're anything but oppressed
and downtrodden
and what's more this is another Hallmark
of modern victimhood they maintain their
victimhood delusions even as they
viciously attack the ones they claim to
be helplessly victimized by
so Harry has turned on his own family
aired their dirty laundry monetized its
airing
and yet still pretends to be somehow the
injured party
now are there tears fake
is it all an act
well yes and no yes in the sense that
Meghan Markle is a sociopath who has
probably never experienced a fully
authentic human emotion in her life but
know in the sense that you know to the
extent they can feel emotions at all
they are actually upset I believe that
part
because part of the curse of being a
narcissist
is that you're never satisfied no matter
how much attention you get It's never
enough
so long as you remain still standing on
a planet that revolves around the Sun
rather than around you so so long as
there are people out there living lives
that have nothing to do with you and
talking about things other than you and
prioritizing their own well-being over
yours
so long as any of that remains the case
you will feel persecuted
because narcissism is insatiable
there are no happy narcissists no
content narcissists
whatever they have they should always
have more in their minds whatever anyone
else does or says they should have
always done or said something different
they're always being attacked
they're always being conspired against
everyone is Whispering about them behind
their backs they think
narcissism and victimhood go hand in
hand our culture of victimhood is really
then a culture of narcissism
and Harry and Megan are
it's perfect Representatives
and Creations
and for that they are today
canceled and that'll do it for this
portion of the show as we move over to
the members block hope to see you there
if not we'll talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]